hi everyone I'm Josiah Matthew me from
the Google Play team and I'm here to
talk to you about Google Play for
education
imagine a world where every student and
classroom is connected to the web
imagine all the teachers are able to
find any piece of content they want and
get it to the right group of students at
Google we've started to make that vision
a reality with Google Play for education
it's a new initiative combining portable
Nexus tablets with highly engaging
content so it includes a dedicated
online store and this is different from
Google Play and it's just for educators
where content including apps books video
is organized by subject by grade by
co-curriculum just the way teachers
search for it it includes tablets that
are priced affordably because we want to
bring that promise of one-to-one
learning into the classroom it includes
easy purchasing options for schools so
for example a teacher can purchase an
app and try it for free they can do bulk
purchasing they can also use purchase
orders instead of credit cards since as
a school you don't have credit cards and
also includes centralized distribution
of apps and content directly to devices
with one click so what's the opportunity
here for you it's in 3d Living Color
specifically in distribution discovery
and delivery so you're an app developer
creating apps for schools wanting to
reach students and teachers directly
Google Play for education will help you
reach that audience without having to
create a Salesforce you're creating an
app and you want it to be discovered by
teachers looking for that particular
piece of content the way Google Play is
for education is organized teachers can
search by subject by grade by
co-curriculum component in a variety of
ways to be able to find your app without
having to go through all the noise and
clutter and then finally if you want
your app to be purchased in bulk at a
classroom level as
cool level at a district level or even
the state level you don't have to do
anything with Google Play for education
we allow teachers to buy in bulk and
also with one click to provision it to
different devices so Google's presence
in education includes Google Apps for
Edie you got 25 million users worldwide
over 3,000 schools using Chromebooks and
over 700 thousand YouTube videos in edu
and what that has done that footprint
has helped us establish a ecosystem of
partners in the educational space and
those partners in educators came to us
announced what are we doing in mobile
and that Google Play for education is
the answer to them it's a natural
progression in Google's educational sort
of footprint speaking of um teacher
feedback we've actually been piloting
this in a variety of schools across the
country and got a lot of feedback from
educators on what they look for in apps
and I wanted to share that with you that
so these are some of the things that you
would want your app to be strong in
educational content is a no brainer
especially if it maps to curriculum by
appropriate teachers definitely care
about that they also wanted to be tablet
optimized since we're using Android
specifically Nexus 7 tablets for this
you want to make sure that they have a
good user experience it goes without
saying if you're creating something for
the k-12 market you need to adhere both
to regulations as well as common sense
so it shouldn't collect personally
identifiable information it should not
have a sense of content etc and another
piece of feedback that we've been
hearing a lot from across the board is
that teachers and students don't want to
remember multiple login credentials to
get access to apps so we encourage you
to use google sign-on so that with one
user name and password they can access
all the great content on their tablets
so let's take a look at Google Play for
education so here's the interface with
subjects organized by subjects on the
left side so let's say I'm a math
teacher teaching fourth grade math and I
really want to teach my students about
prime factors today
I can select mathematics and then I can
also up here select by grade this is 4th
grade and this gives me all the
different apps of 4th grade and I am
looking for something 4 factors and this
is the particular aspect in the core
curriculum that maps to that so with
just a couple of clicks I've been able
to access all the different apps that
map to what I need to teach that day I
can further filter it by different type
so I can get other content like books
and videos I can search for free or paid
I can look for which ones are top-rated
and then I can also look at the intended
user so if I want to instruct today if I
wanted as a review tool student tool etc
so this particular app looks interesting
let's get more information on that and I
see it has a badge for Q which means
that an external vendor Q has reviewed
it and found that it is appropriate for
teachers and I know that Q is composed
of teachers were reviewing apps and so
as a teacher I really can rest assured
that this app corresponds to what I need
to teach when I click on order I'm able
to select a group of students that I
already had set up my fourth grade class
and enter that group in there and with
one click I'm going to be able to send
this app to all the devices I want to
also now show you how you can purchase
using purchase orders and for this I'm
in earth science chair at the school
looking for an app regarding the solar
system now I knew I had checked this app
earlier through the free trial and liked
it it was Q proof which is great and I
want to get it for my 5th and 6th grade
class and there's about 150 students so
I'm going to click on I'm going to enter
150 there and notice how the price
changes dynamically and when I click on
this it actually takes me to a screen
where I can select one of three POS my
school has opened with Google already
and use one of them to pay for this so
no more having to pay with my credit
card and then getting reimbursement for
that
and then finally I want to show you how
can you search for all sorts of content
on this so I'm a chemistry club
president and I'm looking for content on
the periodic table and I don't know what
exactly I'm looking for but I know I
want to send some interesting content
out I can just search by periodic table
and I find not just a list of great apps
but also books related to the periodic
table as well as videos so I want to
check out this Khan Academy video on the
periodic table and I'm able to look at
it right there within Google Play for
education to determine whether or not
it's something that I'd want to send to
students and it is and great I'm able to
order it and again having set up the
chemistry club group at my school
earlier with 1-click I'm able to send it
to specifically those devices so that
was a quick view of Google Play for
education I encourage you to go to
developer.android.com slash edu where
there's a lot more details on what I was
talking about and also a chance to sign
up to get more information as it becomes
available and together with you guys and
Google we can actually help transform
k-12 education and make that vision I
was talking about earlier reality thank
you so much for your interest